foreign
they've been asking fans have been
asking for this one for a little bit
um I thought it might be nice to talk
about it now what is everybody's view on
God
oh boy which one how about the Blues
Brothers go first top three God top
three Gods top three didn't we do one
about christianities bottom three what
in what ways top five other two yeah how
Christian are you
from one to ten I'm Kristen he did no
okay no why we left the church I think
that's the thing okay
my view on the supernet this little help
is that the super Nat is something
that's just so super that is natural
Steve's chicken said it was just so
profound I was touched by it honestly I
was touched by Steve don't like that one
dude no I was I was moved okay so this
concept okay this is I think this is
what happens is like if you're born into
religion you go through this phase of
you're just indoctrinated right and then
you kind of go through your own journey
of wait a minute do I really believe and
then that either makes you born again
you get deeper in it you go atheist
right and then so you might go atheist
but then you might go so hardcore that
everything you do you hate everything
religious but then that's just a whole
culture of hate
and then you find some balance and you
go
well maybe I shouldn't rule out
everything because who [__] actually
knows no one knows no one knows and
eventually I believe that we will figure
out some phenomena that happens like
like how they thought disease and
sickness was just being possessed or
like [__] whatever right like mental
diseases were just because I don't know
like you had a demon in you I do believe
that as we further our knowledge in
Science and Tech and all that and we
have the tools to measure certain things
we might be able to figure out a lot
more things but I don't know if it's
like maybe homosexual audience because
there's a demon exactly like you know
maybe it's all because there's a demon
in you instead of just like a couple of
categories yeah I would really like to
to um entertain that thought well I
can't wait till they figure that out
yeah this entity or whatever it's it's
[__] hard man because it's just a
faith-based thing yeah yeah I think we
just all try to believe in something
that helps us understand what we can't
understand whether that's different
religions spirituality
you guys all have Shades yeah yeah
where's your Shades cool guy
that was a knot I heard the knot yeah
not Nat
I think our religion is like so as a kid
right you're told a certain that and
then they're like but also so like
you're told about Jesus and you're told
about all the different like Apostles
and all that kind of [__] and then you
talk about the prophets and all that
kind of [__] but then it's like also
there's Santa Claus and but he's a hoax
yeah and so then you're like man that is
like basically it's almost like it was
set up by people who hate Christianity
or whatever to like sort of give you a
little truth serum to wake you up to the
rest of the scam because then it's like
oh [__] Santa Claus is all [__] and
then by the way if they should just
abandon the Easter Bunny because Easter
Bunny seems like [__] when you're a
kid even kids don't even care about
these kids are like this seems like
[__] wacky you're two years old
you're like I don't know about this
Easter Bunny [__] yeah but I thought
Santa was Christian
Old Saint Peter Nick yeah it's Catholic
Christians all that [__] but but I just
so I think it's just sort of like it's
almost like it just teaches you to not
believe in the rest of it because of it
oh yeah I mean because that's the
gateway to questioning it exactly
because well Santa's not real then why
is Jesus real well Jesus is a historical
figure well so is Santa it's like oh
well [__] I don't [__] know I don't
[__] know that's what my dad said I
don't [__] know I don't [__] know
okay that's what Dad said yeah
and then if I had to choose between
worshiping uh Jesus or Santa I think
I'll go with Santa you love Santa I love
Santa dude Santa's cool man worship
Santa like in come on dude like you got
one in the Middle East
and it's like hot and dry and he's like
he's always scary on the cross and then
you got the other guy he's happy as [__]
what's happening
is that biblical no like you go to a
Catholic Church they got bleeding Jesus
and like this is pretty hardcore we
didn't grow up in that kind of church if
you go to a Protestant or like just
regular like [__] good old-fashioned
American Church like it's like you don't
have dead ass Jesus like Attitude Era
Jesus no like they got saggies this
isn't breaking glass on his forehead bcw
Jesus dude you don't even see Jesus you
see a painting of like a white guy with
a robe on like with always like clouds
and stuff right yeah it's different but
then like when you see sad Jesus you're
just like oh that's scary bro why would
anyone wear a crown of thorns is my
thing
but also we were I mean we grew up with
the 10 strict original Commandments you
can't even paint Jesus that's true
you're supposed to look at him at all
really look at Jesus isn't that funny
all it's all the kind of the same
because you can't like paint the prophet
Muhammad right sure yeah you can't draw
him and all especially in cartoons right
yeah
they all share the same books to the Old
Testament same flood yeah they're all
driven from like the oldest tomes
possible but yeah Nick what's your views
on God I grew up like not really having
conversations about God you know or like
Christianity or anything my mom wouldn't
mention it here and there you know but I
just was like I didn't really know
anything about it and then around Middle
School my mom wanted to put me in a
Christian School
and I was like all right [__] it let's
go and then the whole time [__] dog
Mo Jesus and then the whole time my dad
was like don't believe any of that [__]
so he's like telling me what yeah he
just was like he's like don't let him
[__] brainwash you it's all [__]
nonsense he's here to say like that so
your mom is Christian but your dad's not
she I don't like I don't know what how
she grew up as far as religion
um I think she would go to church a
little bit but I think it's very loose
you know like and I think that's how
kind of I am these days it's like it's
very loose how I think about religion in
God but for the most part too like half
a good chunk of our family is like
Muslim right and my mom's side in
Singapore and then a good chunk of my
mom's beliefs I think are a Christian
but it's very loose you know um but
growing up so I went to Christian School
I didn't know anything about it all
these kids were like have you accepted
Jesus as your lord and savior and I was
like what like what are you talking
about and they're like well Jesus Lord
and Savior blah blah blah this is what
heaven is you should accept Jesus as
your lord and savior so you can go to
heaven and I was like okay I'll do that
tonight so I was like oh yeah I accept
Jesus my Lord's savior because they're
asking you know I'm gonna start doing
all that stuff but I didn't really have
any core understanding of what the Bible
I had no context like going into it
because they're they're asking about uh
how we feel about God right or what is
your views on God what is your religious
beliefs if any oh [__] no this is right
everything's correct still okay we
[__] up huh we gonna do it again no
it's good no it's fine it's a
conversation what are your what are your
current views like where did you end up
basically yeah
why what did you did you think your
answer didn't apply is I thought it was
good
no because then we we mix religion
with God because it kind of is the same
yeah depending on what what your
understanding of God is right but then
like
so I don't think I'd go back to an
institution but I do see myself getting
deeper into religious or Bible studies
and then maybe having a spiritual
connection but I I would I would like to
I don't know so the thing with
institutions right is it's easily
corruptable there's so many Hypocrites
you have a hierarchy
um and and then like I might disagree
with their philosophy or how they
interpret it so so so then it gets heady
and I think that pulls away maybe from
from maybe plus the hardcore people just
ruin everything that's the thing I heard
that if it's too much if it's shoved
down your throat it's hard like like
veganism yeah yeah people can't even
dance because like there should be
dancing about God or some [__] it's like
yeah god dude what's in about incapable
religion like that yeah it's like they
just make up the stupidest rules and it
turns you off right yeah what happened
to me like it's illogical Christian
School turned me off and I was like I
was like dude I'm an atheist I guess I
would label myself that for a while yeah
and then once I started getting older
and started hanging out with different
people from different religions you
realize like oh so much of it is way
more cultural than anything else like
it's not really about like of course
it's the word butts depending who you
hang out with but it's like it's
dependent on what the message of the
religion is but for the most part it's
like how what you do every day like so
much of people's events and their
cultures based off how they go to church
the things they do before and after
church or whatever and their Community
within Church yeah so like I think the
more I hang around with everyone I
realize that like oh yeah like
everything is good like you could take
pieces from Christianity or or
Islam and you could find something in
the middle of like oh yeah like these
are all great messages but what you
choose to leave your life by is your own
business you know but how you view faith
and everything sure and I thought it was
kind of my attitude anytime uh there's a
lot of humans that come together they
just [__] it all up
like I don't know call me like [__]
cynical but it's like
so when there's power and influence and
things like that right it attracts the
wrong people most religions all it's
supposed to do is create an organized
Society where everyone agrees upon the
rules and also creates a system of like
caring for each other yeah but almost
every single [__] religion does the
opposite of what they're supposed to do
you know like oh yeah they're supposed
it's like love your neighbor but then
they can't stop judging the [__] out of
each other and then being parents to
each other are they like you come into a
church there's so much rumors and drama
and people talking [__] behind each
other's backs and it's like where's the
where's the love here like I don't get
it right or like there's just a lot of
these like snobbery and just every
institution has this and then to me I'm
like
um maybe it's just better to have small
Bible study groups or like people that
are like-minded and it's just like let's
just do community service and then I'm
like that's effective and that's pretty
solid but you don't always have to do it
in under the guise of a religion or God
and I'm like now I just want to connect
with people that are
um a part of
doing effective things rather than being
like a snobby group that are just like
on their High horses the purists need to
[__] off yeah like the purest or the
worst part of it because then it's like
you're not in because of that you're not
in because you're gay you're not in
because of that go because you do this
you're not in yeah it's like oh my god
dude like there's no room for like
literally what Jesus was talking about
it's just forgiveness and stuff it's
when there's rules yeah you know there's
no right or wrong everyone can believe
in what they want a lot of these
religions have different Idols but
similar stories and beliefs and ways of
life that people should live by to be a
good person and to you know be grounded
and find an understanding yeah um so I
think it it just depends what was your
personal like road with that
um I mean kind of similar my family
wasn't super religious we went to church
and stuff growing up my my grandma and
some other relatives were pretty
religious but I did like Sunday school
when I was really little but kind of
just weaved onto that but I think I
found my beliefs in spirituality just
more so on my own and figuring out what
I truly believe in and what I want to
live by every day so I mean it's still
figuring it out I don't know which is
what
which is what yeah I mean I do believe
there's some sort of higher power or
understanding that I can't comprehend
and I think it's just things in life
that are
I don't know Finding ways to ground
myself and deal with situations and you
know creating my own belief system I
don't think it goes in any specific
category
um I would be curious honestly to try
out different religions you know
understand what other people believe but
on my own terms I feel
you know
go try the cold [__] last party try it
first
you want a good foundational system try
it first and just see do the more like
less commitment ones I also it's hard
without seeing it you know yeah yeah I'm
like my brain I like
I like proof and understanding and
science it's hard for me to believe in
something if I don't have a physical
proof or reason because you're a little
more of a real no I don't think I've
personally yet experienced something
where
I'm like oh my God that was God I you
know he's talking to me I haven't had
that yet so I don't know that's that's
kind of where I'm at it's complicated
but for me it's it's hard to not see the
clear Money Maker all of them turn into
like you go in right and you see this
[__] cold ass statue with like gold
[__] finishing and the best like
jewelry in the robes and then like you
come in and then
and then I'm like so you're telling me
if I pay x amount of dollars my you know
curses or sins or whatever it's forgiven
and it's like
hey that's kind of scab over here's 10
grand I'm gonna do whatever sins I want
what's God's venmo right and then you go
to every single in religious institution
like you go to like um like a Buddhist
or Shinto temple in Japan like there's
wishing wells and then they they don't
[__] around there's a menu right there
and they're like for a hundred bucks you
get this wishing you for a thousand
bucks you could wish whatever it's
straight up there's a [__] menu and
then so I'm like I prefer a menu yeah
and I'm like you know I want an A on my
10. mozzarella sticks yeah yeah I'm
gonna spend a grand yeah I'm on a on my
test I'm gonna do that you know so like
it beats passing around the guilt basket
for sure yeah it's like just from the
other direction I pretend like I don't
see it what about uh what about you
Colleen um so I went to a private
Christian School in elementary school
and we even had class for church where
like the whole school would have to go
to church chapel chapel yeah Chapel
that's what it's called and um in in
school I've always been a very curious
person so as a kid I would just always
ask questions and there are certain
questions that I was asking as a kid
that would disrupt the classroom or
great or you were the one about is Santa
real the point where I was getting calls
home based yeah some questions yeah it
only got the answers my dad was atheist
my mom's Christian oh and so you know my
mom would probably scold me a little bit
uh my dad would pull me aside and say
never stop asking questions
for real though
um yeah so how conflicting and yeah well
yeah my dad pulled me aside I was a
daddy's girl though too
um so he pulled me I never stop asking
questions and my dad was the type of
person that
um actually kind of like dove into
different religions and again cool
different things that he thought
resonated with him and applied it to his
own life yeah
um
so uh my first impression of religion
was very controlling and felt like you
were allowed to ask questions and if you
did then you were the problem
and it was just that conditioning that I
was just like there's something up about
that
um so yeah I think that you say Jesus is
the truth the way the life I'm like bro
just chill like a little bit yeah yeah
yeah it's a little how are you so sure
well see it'd be like it'd be like
statements like that to be like
so how much of the truth and what is the
truth right
they couldn't answer well there's no
answer there's no answer it's just well
that's what Jesus would do right yeah I
don't like the cop-out answer we put an
ice cube in the boiling water real quick
and just make sure we cannot exactly
right disrupting classes
Proclaim Authority argument that they
they're like I talked to God the other
day and then this and this and I'm like
well why why do you get to have
authority what Discord server was that
yeah or like or like they would you know
people would do this all the time where
they would like disguise their true
intentions behind what God Said but then
you're like that that's not what
happened that's your interpretation
that's whatever and then you're like
well you can't be you can't speak from
Authority here because we both can that
was my problem I was just like you don't
have an answer that seems rational to me
yeah and it was just like that's just
the way it is and so to me that just
never made sense in my head because but
then it's like okay well you know
religions a sense of belief and belief
is a whole other topic and have faith
right faith is the part that always gets
me a little bit right yeah right that
argument this is the flaw
well two also two I was raised around
like you know this very Southern woman
my mom's Southern too but this very very
very Southern woman from like the pit of
Georgia
um she wouldn't even let her kids wear
like Disney sweaters because that's like
worship which false god it's like a
[__] what the [__] extremist there's
no joy in anything like you can't even
watch a movie or something because you
might like it too much and you don't
you're not paying attention to Jesus
secular sir that's a false idol as well
right everything [__] everything bro
on the flip side though I do there are a
lot of things that I missed about being
a part of a religion in the church in
the community because it's like a huge
family right like you know whatever that
just gossips all the time yeah but there
are people you like from there and every
week there's something going on and then
there's just like there's a feeling
behind everyone working together on a
cause so like if you go together uh on a
mission trip or something like that
right and you can do that secular like
join a non-profit or whatever ever but I
think just the whole growing up together
in a town-like Community when you live
in a big city I think that we it's so
easy to be isolated or in small clicks
when you're in a big city or too
independent to where you feel kind of
lonely so I think the social aspect is
pretty cool another thing is like
everyone believing the same thing
I think that it creates some form of
uniformity when it comes to like the
rules are the same you know what I mean
like like the ethics are the same the
rules are the same yeah you have like
gossip but it's not as different as like
I feel like I could I could trust the
members sure versus like it might be a
false sense of trust but I don't feel
like anyone's out here to steal from me
and kill me right whereas like in the
outside world like you don't really know
you got to build that Rapport right you
don't really know your co-worker could
be a person that could kill you you
don't know yeah right
yeah I think uh coming from like because
we grew up so strictly like I feel like
I went full circle from being like a
hardcore like I was a hardcore Christian
I was that annoying person that was
always trying to witness or always
trying to like skew the conversation
towards a way that I can score god
points you know it was very much that
and then um yeah right it becomes
competitive at a point of Christian Arts
yeah and then um and then again you you
realize later that it was never really
about
God like it was about everything else
yeah yeah and that's the thing that like
now that you know after I've distanced
myself from that and the big Catalyst
that really severed the tie was seeing
was going to one of those Mega meetings
like I flew to Florida and I saw how
much money they were asking from all
these broke people and I was like I just
can't see them doing this every single
day and like you really just see the
system and that's what turns you off to
it but also like I try to maintain a lot
of the good things that I've learned
because we're at a micro scale there's
such great interactions person to person
at the same time you know religion as a
whole is it responsible for some of the
bloodiest battles the globe has ever
seen of course but then you know at a
smaller scale like the the values and
the the like Minds that come from that
there's so much treasure there too and
uh no nobody gets the community aspect
more writer than some religions do you
know and I mean think about the some of
the most religious and traditional
cultures
they have they have the lowest for
divorce rate they have they still have
kids they they're not like big city
atheists where we're so lonely we don't
have kids we don't [__] you know it's
just so different yeah so like so like
you know like the uh um what do you call
it like um they're saying Mormons and
like a lot of the pilgrims are not
pilgrims but Quakers those communities
are actually still popping out kids and
they're the they're the ones preserving
like the Western World or something yeah
yeah I think nowadays I have more I have
more respect for religion than I did
when I was in the religion which is yeah
same like I don't I never want to
dissuade anybody from I don't want to
tell them that God's not real that's not
interesting to me like if you believe in
that and you're a good person I don't
want to change anything about you like
you've got it you know because if that's
what it takes for you to live happily
and what business is that of mine like I
love when people are happy doing what
they do and believing what they believe
it has no effect on you exactly but it's
but from my own personal Road like yeah
I didn't end up in the same place as
them but I understand it and I love it
and I think that's amazing that people
can exist there and you know just be the
best people they can be I didn't care
about God or anything like that until I
found Joel Osteen's church and now I'm
all in he's the man because because like
I believe in having like the biggest
church you could ever have and it's his
church is way nice than everyone else
you need a big church so that you can
reach God because God wants you to be
rich dude yeah exactly God wants you to
project his voice as big as loudly as
loud you know God wants me to have a
private plane so I could get closer to
him so he no he can spread the word with
more like easier and without waiting in
line that's true at the airport faster
time is money exactly yeah the magnitude
of that so staggering there's a reason
what do you think about our cute little
churches and then you look at that it's
like temples bro
there's a really good movie that
recently came out it was about a
preaching couple that became one of the
first um yes yeah TBN or whatever yeah
they made sick money dude they were the
people who did the holy water in the in
the mail I think yeah yeah yeah holy
water yeah they won Channel 40.
foreign